okay let me take a few paper towels
okay so i'm going to cover the screen
with paper towels
oh but it covers the camera too but the
whole idea
is i'm blocking my board vision and then
i accept brigham
okay so i don't see the board now i'm
gonna put on my blindfold
i can't see the board the the text thing
is is active
i have to know what color i am right
okay um
where's the okay so i took off the paper
towel
um and then
i guess i'm white
five minutes oh okay so we're just
playing your fight in the game
so this is chess 960
um which means i should start with a
night move let's say knight
b3 oh oh so brigham's white oh
interesting i was gonna try moves so b3
so there's probably a bishop on on c1
um can i play knight f6
i can't play knight f6 can i play knight
oh he could have a bishop on
can i play knight e6 e6 okay
so i have a knight on f8 or it was
probably a bad move
or d8
d3 wait what d3 d3
so b3 d3 it's a weird setup
um
man this is so difficult because i don't
know where the knight
came from um
let's play d5 d5
elephant c3
oh so a bishop a bishop probably came
from from e1
um oh there could be a queen on a12
let's play f6
just blocking this diagonal
man i've this is really difficult
because i don't know where the bishop
the bishop came from it either came from
a1
what e4 e4 so attacking my pawn
um i'm just gonna play d4
d4 and hope that nothing is attacking
[Music]
i i hope that there's no queen bishop
battery
but could be i guess
elephant eats day four yeah okay knight
d4
lady it's day four what
lady oh [ __ ] oh he pre-moved okay
okay so we traded uh so i have queen on
eight
can i play knight c6 you know i can't
play knight c6
can i play i could play e5 maybe
e5 okay so i lost a pawn but at least i
kind of know where things are
ladies e5 danger oh my king's on f8
the king has to be on f8 lady c5
danger if i play 97
i can't play 97 can i play
maybe bishop e7 no
96 no
oh this is tough okay can you have
seven's a move
but i can't play 97 i can't play 96
uh maybe rook d6 i can't move a rook
and my pawns i have to play king f7
oh unless i have a queen let's try 27 no
queen
no i can't move a queen
i can't move a rook can't move a knight
i can move my bishop bishop d6 no
bishop e i'm so confused
king f7 i guess
what's letting me move a bishop though
three
where's the e3
okay i'll play b6 e6
i'm hoping c7 is defended somehow
so i probably have a knight on h8
it couldn't be on aids or b8 maybe
lady c4 danger oh it's another check do
i have bishop e6 please
no 96 no
rook i'm just playing f8
okay so i did have an island h8
or d8 i guess no
oh no because the king
the king's on f8 so the other knight had
started on d8
so white house knight in d1 king on f1
lady b4 danger
b4 okay so i know i can play c5
how much time do i have 3 minutes 46
seconds
black 2 minutes 34 seconds
234 okay
so where's my where are my bishops
thanks for the bits the tts is 500 i
forgot to
to imagine that lady
lady d2 let's play g6 g5 no
not g5 i meant to play g6
so lady went back to d2
so i basically just gave white and
outposts
we'll see h g3 oh some lights
might developed elephant
okay so i have bishop on d7 probably
came from e8
oh which means white has a bishop on e1
and the structure so white has pawns on
e4 d3 c2 b3 a2
um my structures
white kingside castle interesting i
assume i have a rook on g8
bishop on d7 where's my other bishop
maybe oh probably b8
and rook on c8 okay
so let's play let's play rookie chat
beginning to understand the position now
queen's on d2
wait what's my time two minutes 36
seconds
black two minutes five seconds
b4 okay let's play h5
thanks for subbing by the way so i wanna
um i just wanna play h4
i have a pretty good sense of what's
happening on the king side
because the knights are communicating
with each other the structure is
actually well defined
oh but white still has a pawn on f2 h4
he plays h4 after castling
i guess there's some logic to that
if i take i think i'll just take and
play
oh the queen's attacking g5 though
let's um let's take gh4
expecting knight h4
and then
maybe bishop d6 elephant d6
so trying to build a pressure against
the pawn on b4
bishop c5 bec5
so i have a bishop aimed at white's king
and i have a a rook i think my rook's on
c8 and h8
horsey g f5
okay
so we could swap
thinking knight g5 here
just trying to do damage
c6 oh
no i just blunder
do i ever work on yet no my rook's on c8
ooh
i forgot about that flavor g8
i'm losing a row i'm losing my um my
rook on ca2 oh that's so sad
wait knight
knight lady
c8 i thought my bishop was on c5
though was on d6
oh when i so when i took on c5 i typed
bc5
but it moved my b pawn not my bishop
oh that's why i was confused
i'll address this after the game so i
basically just lost a whole
rook so i lost the bishop and lost
exchange
still trying to fight so knights on each
four
um let's play queen g4
wait why can't i play queen g4 oh my
bishop my um let's play bishop h3
h3 why played c3
oh because there's a bishop on b1 ah
and rook i guess is on c1
0 46 seconds black
0 g 63
ladies say three
this is very close to winning
f3 maybe um queen h4
i don't know if there's increments
or f2 let's do um
knight h3
[Music]
queen yes meat right
yes okay
oh there wasn't kermit man
a lot went wrong in that game a lot went
wrong
thanks for the bits cry
so yeah i understood that this these
things were here
so what threw me off
oh bing bing boom what threw me off was
oh hello youtube yeah that was so that
was my first
blindfold 960 game it was not easy
my my opening strategy was terrible
because i
there there were so many um
[Music]
so many different scenarios that could
have been possible
but okay let's let's go through it
let's go standard
thanks richter's neighbor
okay so white started with b3 so this
was a bad move to start with
because first of all in general you
should not block like a center pawn with
a knight
but also i was just trying to figure out
where my knight was
and upon moving it here i realized
i could either have the knight come from
d8 or f8
so now i had to keep two versions of the
position in my mind
of knights coming from either square
and then i had to like be aware that a
knight could either be on f1
or d1 because the position is mirrored
um and then we continued
and yeah i kind of assumed that there
was a battery because white had started
with b3
and moved the bishop here but i mean i
played d4
just to try and seek information um
so once this happened i guess i could
have
i could have figured out that i had a
bishop here
i knew i had a queen here
oh thanks noor yeah after doing this i
have a huge respect
um i think uh levy rosman was the first
first streamer to try this he did it
with like the invisible pieces
um where he wasn't typing the moves but
it was very similar
and in this position i was trying to
like block i was trying to play 97
or um like put anything on e7 or d6 i
tried all the pieces
and nothing worked so king f7 is the
only legal move
it took me over a minute to play king f7
too
and then things continued
yes i knew i knew i was attacking the
queen i knew i was opening the diagonal
again i wanted to block with something
on e6 i guess at this point i still
didn't realize my knight was on each
shape
and then here i realized yeah
oh white was very close to mating
thankfully okay thankfully c5 works
and then yeah then i understood the
structure i saw this very clearly
i was still a little bit hazy on what
was happening on the queen side
and then this okay so lee chess
this is like a weird leeches thing
which i should be aware of because this
has happened maybe once or twice before
so i typed in bc5 intending bishop takes
c5
but it i guess i typed a lowercase b
so it moved upon so next time i should
type
another way to do it you can type d6 c5
um so when i took the pawn i was
envisioning my bishop on c5 and the pawn
still on b6 which
kind of led to me hanging the bishop
and then when white took i i assumed i
basically just assumed that i forgot
that
i forgot to take but then i realized
later that
yeah this um
this happened but then i still have the
tagging potential
i tried to play queen h3 forgetting my
bishop was here so i played bishop h3
and it's tricky for white like this was
i have made in two here
oh knight f3 is made in two so i i
at this point i saw like my queen rook
and knight coordinating
um i was aware of knight f3
i just didn't see i was trying to find
the force mate
i thought this was most likely to lead
to mate because this is a maiden one
threat
but i tried to defend and
actually i forgot there was a pawn on d3
so this is kind of lucky
anyway yeah that was um
it was interesting i might do more of
this
um yeah covering covering the
the whole screen with a paper towel is
one approach
but um have to look into other
approaches